You mentioned I should stop taking my B vitamin supplements. I saw some information about using
organ meat supplements to replenish B vitamins when you have cancer. Should I add that?
You can. So can a cancer patient take organ meat organ supplements? The answer is yes. Well,
what if they have B vitamins? Yeah, that's fine. They don't have methyl B vitamins in them.
So it's the methyl groups in the B supplement that you can't have. Now we have seeking health
brand of methyl free B complex. You could take that, but you could take organ supplements if you
want to. The designs for health has a really good organic organ combination. I think it's got five
different organs. It's called organ synergy. That is a good product that's in powder form and
in capsule form. It's from designs for health. We have it on our website. That's a good product.
You know, a lot of people are on supplement overload. They don't want to add anything else. I get it,
but the powdered organ product you could throw in your smoothie super simple.
So that's the one I would recommend. My daughter uses that. Both my daughters, two of my daughters,
use that for their kids' dance or own in their smoothie or claim a daughter. Even what's that in,
like a soup soups and stuff she makes so her husband will take it. She doesn't tell that she puts it
in there, but it's good for her.